l'italie pays le plus touché d'europe
avec un scénario que redoutent toutes
les autres régions du monde
dans certains territoires italien la
situation paraît hors de contrôle
ce week-end la pandémie a fait près de
1400 morts en moins d'un mois
plus de 5500 décès ont été enregistrés
ce crématorium situé dans le nord de
l'italie est surchargé plus de 170
incinération une semaine pour nous il a
toujours était impératif de traiter le
défunt avec le plus grand respect
cependant à cause du monde espace nous
avons été obligés de laisser des
cercueils sur le sol de la terrasse pour
faire de la place pour les palettes
évidemment ils sont les premiers à
partir mais en attendant ils doivent
passer une journée entière dans cet état
et ça me fait mal au coeur mais nous
n'avons pas d'autre choix l'angoissent
guen le pays et la réalité dépasse
parfois la fiction
à l'image de cette histoire à peine
croyable où près de 650 mille masques
envoyé par la chine ne sont jamais
arrivés en italie
les autorités tchèques ont réquisitionné
la marchandise lors d'une escale à
prague pour les distribuer aux hôpitaux
locaux
une erreur selon la république tchèque
qui a présenté ses excuses à ses
homologues italiens la chine a aussitôt
renvoyé un million de masques à l'italie
sans escale cette fois ci